okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over some of the basic features of
moss and the life cycle and
characteristics that Moss exhibit so
let's go ahead and get started so first
of all just a review plants in general
go through an alternation of generations
and what we mean by that is they they
their life cycle alternates between the
diploid what's called sporophyte stage
and the half-light what's called gimme
the fight stage so if you look in area
one it says a zygote is created from an
egg and a sperm so of the egg and sperm
unites forming a zygote follow the
diagram the zygote will divide by
mitosis and the zygote will divide by
mitosis to create what's called an adult
an adult sporophyte well in the word
sporophyte you can see the prefix for
the word spore so follow the diagram the
adult sporophyte will undergo meiosis
the adult sporophyte will undergo
meiosis to create haploid spores and so
in the picture you see two spores we'll
just follow the arrow is where do the
arrows lead from the spores well first
of all the spores are released into the
air and eventually the spores will land
and when they land they're gonna grow
and here's we just follow the two arrows
when you follow the two arrows it says
some spores will grow and become the
female what's called gametophyte and
other spores will grow and become what's
called the male gametophyte and the word
gametophyte is the term excuse me the
word gametophyte is the term for the
haploid stage in the life of a plant and
in the in the named gametophyte you can
see the prefix for the word gamete so
the gametophyte will create the gametes
in the next area of the diagram in area
6
says the egg and sperm are released by
the gametophyte the female gametophyte
releases the egg the male gametophyte
releases the sperm and so this is why
the called the gametophyte the
gametophyte releases gametes and if you
remember gametes are the sex cells the
egg and the sperm and now we've
completed one rotation around the
alternation of generations I am because
one rotation around the diagram because
we're back to the beginning step 7 right
here is the same as step number 1 the
sperm and the egg cell create a diploid
zygote and so all plants in general do
this now let's focus specifically on
mosses so mosses are in the first group
of plants that we're going to look at
Group one the seedless plants and
they're also non vascular so they do not
make seeds and they don't have a
vascular system so that makes mosses
very very primitive and mosses aren't
the only plants that are seedless and
nonvascular but the majority of this
presentation we're going to focus on
mosses just because they're more common
so what's unique about these seedless
nonvascular plants in which mosses are
examples is that they they typically
live in very moist environments and the
reason they live them in moist
environments is so they can reproduce
male sperm cells of Moss plants have
little flagella on them that will cause
the sperm cell to swim eventually
fertilizing an egg and and you can't
swim through through air so there has to
be moisture on the ground coming from
rain and so here's a couple examples of
plants other than mosses liverworts are
small you can see only grows maybe an
inch or so above the ground a small
seedless non vascular plant
here's another example of a horn words
not a very attractive looking plant you
can see it just almost looks like green
spiky grass blades sticking out of the
dirt and the majority of this video
again we're gonna focus on
bosses so I think you guys are all
familiar with moss if you go hiking you
commonly will see a picture like this
moss a layer of moss growing on a rock
growing on just the path in which you're
walking so mosses are the plants we're
gonna focus on in this presentation
overall Moss liverworts and hornworts
are classified in a very primitive group
of plants this group one the seedless
nonvascular plants the the the official
name for these plants are called
bryophytes again bryophytes are examples
of seedless and nonvascular plants so
they're very primitive plants so let's
go ahead and specifically focus on
mosses so here's another picture fairly
common of what you think of when you see
the word when you see mosses it just
looks like a very very thin layer of
green plants growing on this case it's
like they're growing on rocks so as
mentioned moments at a moment ago mosses
are very primitive they are seedless and
they are non vascular and they're also
very small they're very small because
they are non vascular in order to
transport nutrients a large distance
plants need to have a vascular system
you know some trees can grow hundreds of
feet in height the Sequoias the redwoods
well the reason they can grow so tall is
because they have a vascular system to
carry nutrients from the ground all the
way up a vascular system is not the only
reason why sequoias and redwoods can
grow so tall but it's a very important
factor well mosses don't have a vascular
system so they're not able to transport
nutrients a very great distance so they
have to be so if they don't have a
vascular system well how do they
transfer materials such as water such as
carbon dioxide well they simply transfer
their gases and their nutrients through
simple diffusion in the animation you
see
very simple diffusion of some blue dots
slowly diffusing into the cell the blue
dots in this example represent oxygen
but oxygen diffuses around the cells
carbon dioxide diffuses around moss
cells in water through osmosis diffuses
around the cells of moss if you recall
from the chapter we discussed on ecology
we mentioned that mosses are often
examples of a pioneer species because
they are often one of the earliest
inhabitants of a new ecosystem mosses
along with lichens are some of the first
organisms to inhabit a new area because
they don't require a very thick layer of
soil they can often grow on bare rocks
and they begin the process of turning a
uninhabitable area into a thriving
climax community again the process can
take hundreds of years but moss are what
we consider to be the pioneer species so
here's a picture of some moss zoomed in
pretty closely here and what you're
seeing is a very common common sight
this is typically what moss look like if
you were to get down on your hands and
knees and take a close-up look of them
what we are seeing is what is known as
the gametophyte stage if you recall from
the diagram at the beginning the
gametophyte stage is the haploid stage
so when you look at mosses you are
seeing the haploid gametophyte stage so
each Moss in this picture is the haploid
gametophyte well let's take a look at a
drawing in this drawing we have six Moss
plants and each one of them is a
gametophyte some of the six are male
gametophyte
some of the six are female gametophyte
again the male gametophyte s' will
release sperm the female gametophyte s'
will make eggs so we're gonna go into
more on this in just a moment a quick
note about the structure of mosses if
you notice in the picture they have
little root-like structures that help
them hold
- and anchor themselves into the soil
these are these structures here are
called rhizoids and they serve the
purpose of roots they absorb water they
absorb nutrients from the ground from
the soil and it's a real nice picture
here you can see that the leaves of moss
are very very thin they're typically
only about one cell and thickness so you
can they're almost so thin that they're
transparent and they make for really
good examination underneath a microscope
because their cells are so thin that you
can get a good view of the internal
chloroplasts so now let's go ahead and
look at the lifecycle
how do mosses reproduce what what how is
the pattern of alternation of
generations what does that look like so
as I mentioned a moment ago here is a
nice little picture of a bunch of moss
growing in a forest and what you're
seeing is the gametophyte stage the
gametophyte saved is the dominant stage
it's the common stage it's the prevalent
stage if you recall the gametophyte
there's also the haploid stage and if
you kind of use your imagination this
kind of looks like a layer of thick
green shag carpeting like from the 1970s
now if you weren't alive in the 1970s
you may not know what green shaggy
carpeting looks like so here you go
in this picture there's a picture of
green shaggy carpeting you know this was
the hit in the 1970s this was a very
common a common choice of decoration for
carpeting shaggy thick green carpet and
if you use your imagination it kind of
looks like moss well if we come back to
this diagram that we saw earlier here's
about about 10 10 Moss plants and again
remember each one of them is a
gametophyte well let's focus on one
single male gametophyte from the 10 and
let's focus on one single female
gametophyte from these 10
and so here we go I've identified the
one on the left is the male gametophyte
remember the gametophyte is haploid and
the one on the right is the female
gametophyte remember the female
gametophyte is hap lighting now you
really can't tell the difference between
male and female with an naked eye but if
you were to zoom on into the tips to the
very top tips of the male and female
gametophyte you would see structures
that make the egg and the sperm so at
the tip of the male gametophyte is a
structure that produces a whole bunch of
sperm cells at the tip of the female
gametophyte is a structure that makes a
whole bunch of egg cells again you
really can't see these structures with
the naked eye you have to zoom in
underneath the microscope to see them
but they're there and the way the
lifecycle proceeds is when it rains
watch the animation when it rains here
comes a bunch of rain a layer of
moisture is on the ground and when
there's a layer of moisture on the
ground sperm cells from the tip of the
of the male gametophyte will actually
swim to the tip of the female
gametophyte watch the animation the dots
that are gonna appear represent sperm
cells swimming and so there is an orange
sperm cell that just swam from the male
to the female gametophyte and that
orange circle fertilized an egg and it
created a zygote a zygote if you recall
from earlier in the school year is a
fertilized diploid egg cell and so now
that the rain has dried up it stopped
raining the rain has dried up the male
has fertilized the female and we have a
zygote created so the zygote marks the
beginning of the sporophyte stage the
diploid stage in the life of a plant as
I just mentioned the diploid stage in
the life of a plant begins and starts
with the sporophyte or excuse me the
sporophyte stage begins and starts with
the zygote
so the zygote marks the beginning of the
diploid sporophyte stage I hope I didn't
just confuse anyone there and so
eventually that zygote is gonna grow now
I've over exaggerated the size of the
zygote in this animation I mean a zygote
is still microscopic I've over
exaggerated it just so we could see it a
little better in this animation but what
begins to grow upward you can see with
the naked eye in the animation you see a
stock beginning to grow upward well if
you notice there's a little brown tip on
the top of the stalk that has a name as
well so that brown tip at the top of the
stalk is called a capsule and inside
that capsule will eventually be new
spores new spores are going to be
created that will eventually be released
into the air to restart the lifecycle so
as I just mentioned the inside of that
little capsule meiosis is busily being
performed in order to create haploid
spores and in the animation you can see
a bunch of black dots are being released
from the capsule these are the spores so
the spores are released into the air and
that restarts the cycle it restarts the
cycle because those spores will land on
the ground and they'll grow into some of
the spores will grow into male
gametophyte which will produce sperm
cells and other spores will grow into
the female gametophyte which will
produce the egg cell let's follow a
couple of these watch this so when we
follow these there you see two dark
black dots just landed two spores just
landed well let's have those four on the
Left grow into a male gametophyte
remember that's haploid let's have the
spore on the right grow into the female
gametophyte remember the gametophyte sar
always happily and so in order to
sexually reproduce
in order to sexually reproduce rain will
fall and once there's a layer of
moisture on the ground
watch the orange sperm cells swim to the
female gametophyte again I've over
exaggerated the size of the zygote in
this animation just so we can kind of
see it the zygote is still small
microscopic but once the sperm swims to
the female egg cells I go the diploid
zygote is created and when the diploid
zygote is created this structure begins
to grow I have two question marks what
do we call the name of the bottom
question mark well that would be the
stalk what do we call the name of the
top question mark that would be called
the capsule so you can see we're just
repeating the notes that we took a few
moments ago you can see in the animation
black dots representing spores of being
released from the capsule and the
process would continue again the process
would repeat again so there's a
wonderful actual picture of you can see
the brown sporophytes growing up out of
the green gametophyte so there's about
looks like I'm counting about seven
different Brown sporophytes in that
picture you can see seven capsules and
those will eventually release spores
into the air and so now that I now that
we've kind of gone through that cycle if
we were in class I would you know have
you guys work with your neighbor for a
minute to answer these questions if
you're watching the video at home on
YouTube well pause the video pause the
video right now and try to answer these
questions I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one
alright so identifying the letters ABCDE
and F letter A I hope you chose the
capsule letter B I hope you chose the
stock letter C
you chose that's the area where the
zygote is created now you can't actually
see the zygote in this picture but in
that area there at the top of the
gametophyte is where the zygote will be
will be formed letter D I hope you chose
the route like structure is called the
rhizoids letter e is put in the bracket
around the entire sporophyte stage and
letter F is putting a bracket around the
entire gametophyte stage
well now let's move on to questions two
three four five and six question number
two overall which area is haploid I hope
you chose letter F the gametophyte is
the name of the haploid stage for number
three which area is overall which area
is diploid I hope you chose letter e
again the sporophyte is the name of the
diploid stage number four spores are
released from which letter I hope you
chose letter A spores are released from
inside of letter A the capsule number
five which area marks the start of the
sporophyte stage I hope you chose letter
C because in that area where the zygote
is created the zygote marks the
beginning of the diploid stage in the
life of a plant and then question number
six which objects the Anna the answer is
not pictured which objects are the start
to the gametophyte stage
the answer is spores spores at the
beginning of the gametophyte stage and
so hopefully this was a nice little
review well here's another little review
again if we were in class I'll give you
a minute to solve the problem if you're
watching hit the pause button and try to
put these steps in order I've given you
step number one come up with step two
three four five and six I'm gonna go
over the answer in three two one
okay so one spores land on the ground
what happens next I hope you chose the
moss gametophyte swill grow near the
ground because when spores land some of
the spores will grow into male
gametophyte
some of the spores will grow into female
gametophyte and what comes next step
number three was would be well through
water sperm from the male gametophyte
will swim to the female gametophyte and
once that happens I hope you chose step
number four step number four would be
the process of fertilization so in step
three
sperm are swimming to the feet from the
male gametophyte to the female
gametophyte that will lead to
fertilization fertilization is when the
sperm and egg unite and fuse together
that's step four fertilization occurs
after fertilization occurs I hope you
chose step number five the diploid
sporophyte will begin to grow from the
zygote and then once that happens I hope
you chose for step number six the
sporophyte will create and release
spores and the process will repeat the
process will repeat because once the
sporophyte will create and release
spores step number one happens the
spores land which leads to step two
three four five and six and we're in a
constant repeating cycle and so there
you have it that's the end of the of
them information I wanted to share with
you on mosses so if you want to try this
little practice quiz hit the pause
button and answer your and put your
answers on the separate sheet of paper
I'd be happy to check your answers
before class or after school one day for
accuracy so go ahead and pause the video
good luck